So, now,
let's look at these steps one at a time.
Let's first look at the prediction step.
Okay?
So our prediction step is, given some
belief about X of, at t minus one,
and given the measurements
all the way up through t minus one,
make a prediction of Xt.
State of time t, still given only the
measurements through time t minus one.
The way we do that and
I'm, It's going to be written out
here in, in sort of a standard way.
And then we're going to make
specific use of that both,
especially in particle filtering
which we'll do in a little bit.
What, the way you would do
that is what's known as,
you use the law of total probability and
marginalization, allright?
So the law of total
probability marginalization,
I'm only supposed to
be reminding you here,
you're supposed to remember all
your probability theory, right?
Then if I've got a joint density,
right, P of a and b.
If I integrate that over all the b's
what I'm left with is
the density over a.
Allright.
That's marginalization.
So what I'm going to do here is the idea
is well if I had a joint density of
xt minus one,index t and I were to
integrate over all the xt minus ones,
I would just have the density over xt,
so that's the marginalization.
And, the reason we do
that is we can then
break that integral up
into the following, right?
So, you might remember the conditioning,
right, probability of A and
B is the probability of A given B
times the probability of B, it's
what it says down here, so I've just
broken up this integral down into this.
Where here's the probability of xt minus
one given everything up to t minus one.
And I multiple that times the
probability of xt given xt minus one and
everything else.
So I'm just applying the conditioning
property to that interval.
And then I can use that independence
assumption that we said before.
Remember, the independence assumption Is
that if I want the probability of xt,
and I'm given the previous state, and
a bunch of other things,
those other things don't matter.
The only thing that matters
is that previous state.
That's our dynamics model.
So, basically, we have two things here.
We have our belief.
About t minus onr,
giving everything up through t minus
one and then we have our dynamics.
Those are the two components that
it takes in order to make that
guess going forward.